[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein guter tag für das bundesheer ein
guter tag natürlich auch für das
jägerbataillon 17 hier in strass und
damit auch ein guter tag für die
sicherheit österreichs wenn wir die
ersten fünf stück von insgesamt 34 neuen
panduren übergeben mit einem
gesamtinvestment 8 millionen euro
sicherstellung dass zum einen straße das
kompetenzzentrum für die band ude
bleiben wird und auch ist und auf der
anderen seite auch für unsere soldaten
den bestmöglichen schutz für einsätze im
in- und im ausland gewährleisten
insgesamt 1000 über 1000 jetzt im
schneeeinsatz wir halten noch 1000
zusätzlich bereit um hier auch über
längere zeit zu unterstützen
und ja wir haben insgesamt auch über 900
an der grenze hier auch in der
steiermark und in österreich und fast
1000 auch noch im auslandseinsatz das
heißt wir insgesamt mit 3000 soldatinnen
und soldaten ein sehr hohes volumen
bereits an soldaten jetzt im einsatz
aber die österreicher können sicher sein
dass das bundesheer gewehr bei fuß steht
zu helfen und zu schützen dann wenn sie
es brauchen und das auch über längere
zeit
das ist auch ganz klar die anweisungen
die militärische führung priorität haben
jetzt die einsätze
[Musik]